I think a manís a day just looks like
someone who understands what he is and
understands the type of person here I
understood that this is what a man of
today is supposed to be doing going back
to where he's from helping the people
that he couldn't help before because he
may not have had the resources but now
that he does he goes back and extends a
hand through the Victor Cruz foundation
footballs had a tremendous impact in my
life even from you know the age of 11
when I first started playing and my dad
just teaching me and coaching me all the
way through and then fast forward to now
or football and I look back on it's
given me a platform to do so many other
things in my life you know I don't know
where I'd be without it some plays a
huge role I mean I doused myself in
Cologne every day you want that energy
you want people to to ask you questions
about your Cologne I mean you can't tell
me anything I could walk into any room
and feel like I can take over and I can
feel like I can you know dominate any
area that I'm in because I just I look
good I feel good as long as you're
comfortable in your own skin no one can
say anything negative towards you
because you own it and that's what a man
that today is a man of today is someone
who understands who he is
and isn't afraid to bestow that upon his
people and everyone that's around